the perfect window for the perfect
viewing Oh snake I've come for you come
out how's it going everyone welcome back
to potato mode the show where we take
the best looking games out there and
turn the graphics into something not of
this world I'm Joey
I'm joined for the first time by Ben
djenka hello everyone so we're hanging
out here with biker boss and you've got
me set up to do I think it's the first
mission
yeah we're just up for the first mission
and so if you haven't seen the show
before we're gonna take some great
looking games like this like milk your
solid 5 and we're gonna just try to
bring the graphics down as much as we
can in game and then we're gonna just
keep going further we're gonna break
through whatever zero is and going to
the negatives I'm really worried because
this game is darn beautiful it really is
I don't know what the Fox engine uses to
run it's like fairy dust or something
but I'm really I'm really worried let's
see how great the game actually looks
before we destroy everything from the
inside this is we just set up camp here
and like just hang out yeah I'd be down
cook up some s'mores
heck yeah all right it's gonna go for it
just gonna do the thing snakes excited
oh so long so happy yeah the side of him
double yikes
triply Ikes there's a little rusty so I
think we've seen a good amount of the
game looks fantastic yeah yeah but
that's not appropriate for the show and
as typical for our potato mode viewers
everything's gonna be turned on the low
oh man let's try the resolution you
don't hit that resolution to us let's
see see what it gives us dude snake does
not look stoked about this in the
background he's watching you do this he
can see it he knows his coming
our resolutions I can't believe it look
at all right yeah
it looks a bit like it like if you kind
of squint your eyes it looks a bit like
a Bob Ross painting that's pretty good
we got a bunch of happy little trees and
bushes all on me so at this point
nothing has vanished from our UI
yeah we're snake still has a face I
think he does that's marks all right Ben
I'm gonna have to put the brakes on
right here but he's right there I know
he's right there my buddy cause but we
are right here about two potato fly this
game oh no I'm so worried let's do it
well not ground zeroes we're gonna go
into the phantom pain on phantom pain so
many wonderful options but only a few
that will actually do we have a driver
controlled lod bias which we're gonna
turn off we're gonna turn on the LED
bias I'm not gonna be gentle not you're
just gonna no you're gonna go in it's
already the loading thing is already
messed up whine the g-force warning the
button for okay isn't there alright
we're looking good so far
judging by Ben's reaction Oh his hair is
gone Joey hey still has his eye patch so
he's you can still or okay I would say
the bandana is more recognizable than
the eye patch yeah yeah that's fair but
like where's the rest of him just a
giant blobby mess just giant it's this
potato mountains we've reached the
mashed potato mountain good I hope you
memorized what you we have in our
inventory uh which colored block is the
thing that I want now there we go
every box is a box uh I can confirm that
do not discriminate against boxes you
get a cool slide going I guess cuz why
not I don't have a reticle at all people
like just clean you I know HUD I think
that's in these days right yeah yeah
this word this is advancing technology
we're removing or shaken I think I can
see people through walls there we go so
that's that's that's the experts alt
maneuver that everyone's here to look
for
gosh Oh God
are his lips usually that black no they
are not they do something to your right
to soul to my eyes you see the rest of
him oh my gosh he's stereo blind he's
got an eye patch on one of his eyes
maybe he just doesn't notice at all okay
do you mind if I do something real quick
let's not talk about what I just did to
my pal it's fine we're fine so what I
just did was I installed a mod that you
might have seen before within the last
couple weeks because it turns all the
helicopters into revolver ocelot Joe
I've always said I kind of wish the
revolver ocelot would just help out with
this mission he's just kind of like
critiques you know the whole way through
but like now we've got him here MVP by
the way just wanna give a shout out to
the the mod maker of this wonderful
spinning awesome here blaka tui is the
guy who upload this onto Nexus mods and
it's so gosh-darn majestic I'm sorry I'm
in a loss for words at this point but
yeah are we gonna get it always landing
oh he's coming down for a landing oh I
love how his model is also been like
stripped of his textures yeah he's just
just put the cherry on top of this
mashed potato son oh yeah can't we just
can we just
just one of asking this just for a
little bit
[Music]
although you're bleeding out of your
butt I that lets I'm I'm a cool boy
whoa God I can still tell which way is
the right way because you can still see
the the pilot hanging out goal Pequod
eyes get in diamond right there yes the
Diamond Dogs I see it cause you're not
hallucinating
it's totally there it's a high yeah I
see it's a really great logo
get some rest you need you may have
ahead I definitely didn't drop you on
the way out at one point it's happening
here we go okay alright drop into this
place sure I don't likes everything woke
up hmm-hmm-hmm commencing the worst
mission of our lives right here
everything's gonna be a-okay okay so I
know that we've got to go up there oh
she's got good kicks I forgot just
always at least finish up with a kick
she also runs really fast so it makes it
kind of difficult to move around Daisy
oh you got a really nice place this is
really good so this is the cool thing
about her is she can turn invisible okay
so if they come over here and check on
me I'm not here yeah we're good home
free you know it's kind of like life
yeah when you lose it in this case we're
both yeah there's no real winner and
there's no real loser you just kind of
float on by and then they're you and
then you're back on the under helicopter
hanging out with with a low texture
snake let's do one last thing you want
to check out the beginning mission just
to see what happens let's try it yeah
okay this is like eating breakfast for
dinner
doctor doctor crash-test-dummy doctor
you look difficulties
yes he looks like a muppet he looks like
- whoa yeah kind of I'm not I'm not okay
with this
I mean maybe just erased oh she looks
like she's not having a good - Oh
perfect
we can we can change some of that got
giving some wrinkles maximum rank not
doing anything not doing a thing don't
do it you won't no I dare you yeah so
let's start crawling let's get out of
here go go go go God we got places goat
potatoes to be always are all the
helicopters that's good oh yeah
hell yes that's the content I'm looking
for I've never been more excited to see
an attack helicopter in a video game
maybe ever the perfect window for the
perfect viewing oh snake
I've come for you come out all these
people were wearing masks man that's
that's the best of all you'll want to
catch the potato disease yeah see what
has done to everyone here exactly
this is actually an outbreak scenario
were the the last of the the survivors
are trying to team up to stay away from
all the people who are turning into
potatoes
you get him revolving ocelot we would
teach him a lesson what this isn't what
I signed up for
I think that's fire could just be some
really really uh-oh it's definitely fun
yeah that's fire stop drop and roll
I I can't do my dive all I can do is run
around a circus also just like a mask
yeah actually yeah well at the end where
they all shoot him
and he like sucks him in and he starts
spitting them out Oh does he spit about
yeah no he just explodes we would see it
but he's shooting them back out but it
is kind of unexplained explosion of
bullets get in we're going shopping
sure yeah carry was that buy you a shirt
sick of looking at your nasty Mabel
listen honey this is normal this is fine
this is okay oh this is just fine with
dual hip firing action did it leave us
after all huh this is a beautiful image
it's The Flaming whale and a spinning
laughs video games
Joe low texture cowboy it's so grateful
that you're here okay I think I think
we've got it I think we're gonna be okay
I know this forest oh this is this is I
think this is peak like this this is too
intense I'm having a hard time
concentrating
oh my god man I really hope you don't
run into a bridge here Ocelot and trust
in you know we fell into no texture it's
never to be found again
well then yeah yeah I think that about
does it
thank you guys so much for watching this
episode hater mode if you have a game
that you'd like to see potato fide
graphics turned into mush all that jazz
leave in the comments below or hit us up
on Twitter we glad to take your
suggestions and make sure to have a nice
day
and we'll see you next time on Peter
Berg take it easy goodbye okay we got
this
slow motion toss here just Chuck a knife
at something because you just don't know
what else to do people ruff Helene out
of his patience like holy up anxieties
like cars old pockets all these only
soldiers need to get out of here